and joining us in his fourth season in
the National Football League he was one
of the first guys to get there and start
what we're finally seeing the seeds
planted taking root and growing into a
six and O start out of out of the pack
12 out of Oregon DeForest Buckner
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
from the 49ers how you doing - Forrest
I'm doing good thanks for having me rich
you finally dried out from the weekend
oh yeah finally I still got to get my
equipment dry out though you know I mean
some of the photographs we see of the
mud and the dirt and just it looked like
a game it people usually play in their
front or back yards - Forrest that
remind you that when you're playing that
game know definitely on the sideline
we're all talking about it reminded us
reminded us about a playing Pop Warner
just like you just sliding around that's
what you guys did once it was all
settled you you started sliding around
were you one of those guys who hit the
turf yes I definitely was I was right
next to Nick when he slid in my song
slides over yeah let me slide - this was
a lot of fun how many yards Terry did
you have in your slide DeForest you
almost got a first down you almost got a
first down I mean what has it been like
for you there in San Francisco and and
this season in light of what you've been
through there already the forest yeah
there's been a lot of fun man
you know finally seeing everything come
together the pieces you know all coming
together you know the culture the the
team that John and Lynch you know
envision Lynch and Kyle envision when
they came here it's all coming together
you know you know it's been a long run
definitely since I've been here in 2016
we were 2 and 14 so or you know we're
we're a long ways and in terms of what
the anchor is for this team so many
people are mentioning this and I think I
don't you know obviously it's a team
effort it's it's your unit it's that
defensive line that is that is elite and
it's a difference-maker do you guys feel
that way - yeah definitely you know we
definitely feel like we're you know we
gotta set the tone every every game
every day in practice you know you know
we try to come out and set the tone
every day in practice and you know it's
just uh also another another thing that
cooked us Eric brought to the room - you
know he he definitely
but he's bringing a lot out of us you
know all trying to bring our full
potential as a group and you know making
sure we're all playing together and you
know it's just every game we want to go
out there be a difference maker
do you guys have a nickname for the unit
yet now we don't have a nickname for it
yet you know we're gonna keep going keep
seeing how the season goes on but come
on you know we're open top since I don't
know we still don't have a name for the
unit nobody nobody has even thrown one
out there and in the meter I mean
there's been different different uh you
know things being thrown around I've
even hear from outside and you know even
inside one of them were like Avengers
you know what I mean just in the room we
all bring different things to the table
right stuff like that so like something
like that policies frontline nickname
themselves the hot boys last hot boys
yeah heard about that right oh yeah I
definitely heard about that I don't I
don't know I mean how about you could
call yourselves the deep Sixers you know
you'd bury you bury people for the 49ers
the deep Sixers what do you think yeah I
mean yeah it's a good option right there
mm-hmm I guess you know I'm I I've tried
to nickname people in the past DeForest
Buckner and it hasn't done very well I
try to make name Matt Ryan the natural I
keep trying crest it doesn't work even
with no no no skin in the game and they
can't pick it but so your defensive
coordinator DeForest Robert Solow has
been as it's certainly gotten a lot of
attention because how fired up he is
what does he like off camera yeah no
balls like that man
he's been like that since he's gotten
here you know especially on game day
he's always fired up the deepness makes
a big play and you know it's you know
it's him seen seen the scheme and his
guys going out there executing as far as
him up and that's the type of coach he
is and you know he he likes to bring you
know he bring he likes to tell us a
little stories and stuff like that that
relate to you know to the game and also
you know in life little things like that
little life lesson things and
you know the keep was gone and you know
he says he's just a great coordinator he
really cares about each and every one of
the guys on defense and he's just a
passionate coach can you give me an
example of a story throw one out for me
yeah yeah I mean I'm gonna be honest
there's multiple different stories that
he tells and everything and I can't I
can't specifically remember one oh my
god are they are they not safe for work
sometimes is that what you're saying
sometimes sometimes you know it's it
stays in a defensive room I got it what
happens there stays there a couple of
items throughout the season I want to
hit with you a little bit here at
DeForest Buckner obviously the one this
past week where your coach Kyle Shanahan
went back to the spot where he once
coached with his dad and we all know
what happened there were you guys aware
of that going into the game and and
playing for that in a certain way oh you
know we you know you know all over the
story that happened you know with the
with his dad and him being there and you
know going into this game we knew it was
gonna be a little more personal for him
and you know he you know we're a team
you know we got each other's back and
you know as a team we had cows back
going into that weekend and we knew what
kind of game was gonna be how you know
and you know it doesn't matter how the
game was gonna be we just wanted to get
that win for him and in his business
pops and you know at end of the day
everything came out with the win and
that's what all I mattered did he have
to say anything where was this unspoken
I walked me through that know he didn't
really say much you know it was really
the other coaches that were saying it
and uh you know after the game he shared
you know he shared how how big of you
know of this win that mattered to him
and you know he wanted to give the game
ball to his dad and and all that and so
you know he you know having you know us
having his back and going out there you
know that's what that's what the team is
all about then a couple of weeks before
that
DeForest on a Monday night Oh with the
Cleveland Browns and you were out there
as part of the team captains did did
Baker Mayfield shake your hand
uh yeah he did you know initially so let
me clear up the air a little bit so you
know initially when we got out there he
depth everybody up ok shake everybody's
hand and usually after the coin toss
you know the captains on both sides
usually shake each other's hands good
luck a second damping a second time yes
and what everybody did not see was after
the after the coin toss you know we went
in to shake all their hands and he he
was the first one to just run off name
you know while we were you know trying
to reach out and shake it and shake
everybody's hand so that's what Sherman
was talking about and you know that kind
of you know a little fire in our our
asses a little bit and you know yeah and
then that's that
so our you're saying is Baker potential
just a single dapper he just doesn't do
the double DAP maybe just I don't know
you know is that stole his business the
way he goes about his business and uh
you know it's it's out of my hands man
but it just fired you up though that you
know on the spot yeah I mean kind of
fired fired me up a little bit I'm not
gonna lie um you know because you know
as a professional you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell the other guys good luck you
know but right before we get out there
and start hitting each other so you know
I mean that's the way he does his
business I mean I guess what he's been
doing since college maybe I don't know
oh yeah speaking of college DeForest
DeForest Buckner 49ers defense Islam in
here on the Rich Eisen show guys talk in
meeting rooms obviously and you you're
your fellow line mate Nick Bosa planted
the flag know at the end of the end was
he talking about that all week how long
did he have that one yeah he had it I
think he was thinking about that all
week because earlier in the week he told
me he was a yeah when I he was like when
I sacked bakery it was it wasn't if he
was like when I sacked Baker I'm gonna
said back when they played Ohio State
played Oklahoma and Oklahoma came to
Ohio State at the end of the game when
they won he planted the flag in the
middle of the in the middle of the field
and I thought oh yeah you got to do that
celebration bro and he ended up doing it
I was very happy for him yeah and then
he actually planted a literal flag yeah
yeah
oh my gosh seems like you guys are
having a blast so far too far yeah like
you're like you're living in the moment
while also realizing the moment would
that be fair to say definitely
definitely further to the house I mean
so what happens from here though I mean
you got a big game with Carolina coming
up you know this kid Kyle Allen has got
something he's got an it factor kind of
like your quarterback in a way I mean
what happens from here on out the forest
yeah we're just taking it one day at a
time you know you can't get too high
kids can't get too low can't look too
far behind can't look too far forward
man I gotta live in the present and
right now we got Carolina and we're
doing everything we can to get ready for
them and you know it's just taking one
day at a time we got to keep getting
better in practice there's you know an
office is the ball where we can get
better as a team and you know clean up
those little things and you don't get
ready for Sunday and how much do you
guys use the are the 49ers for real
conversation as fuel
oh man it's always gonna be fuel man you
know people's been kind of saw since day
one except for that you know the people
who really been rockin with us was a
faithful and you know it's you know it's
we gotta we gotta show up every day and
take your personal um you know and just
show everybody that you know we offer
real mm-hmm
okay DeForest I appreciate the time I
appreciate the conversation here good
luck against the Carolina Panthers and
you're in a real tough division nobody's
under 500 right there so you're the rear
view mirror there's tons of objects
right there for you best of luck to you
thank you man you got it so I said hello
at the beginning now I'm tapping you up
at the end I'll make sure that you make
sure you get some training for that 40
this year all right oh are you aware
that George Kittel has offered to run
against me no way he has and found them
definitely gonna be tuning in for that
oh well that's gonna happen so and I
will take any tips you know obviously
from someone like yourself where you
know I got I got one for you what are
you going straight allusion otherwise
thanks for the call but that's DeForest
Buckner that's his Twitter handle
at debuck underscore 99 on instagram for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app